[Music]
are you ready kids
aye aye captain with the third spongebob
squarepants movie being released sponge
on the run
it's time for a little character d
briefing
when i ripped my pans
in 1999 the world was introduced to a
little yellow sponge who lived in a
pineapple under the sea
named spongebob squarepants the show
quickly became the most licensed program
ever for nickelodeon it's watched in 185
countries
around the world and his antics are
translated into more than 50 languages
officially licensed spongebob retail has
earned more than 13
billion dollars but perhaps the biggest
currency measure for spongebob's impact
is that the show is referenced at an
average of every four seconds on social
media
day after day year after year all told
spongebob has been an angel sent from
below the sea for nickelodeon
[Music]
okay enough setup let's run through a
brief history of spongebob from top to
bikini bottom
in 1984 stephen hillenburg inspired
since childhood by the aquatic films of
jacques cousteau
was teaching marine biology at the
orange county ocean institute in
southern california
at this time the world of film animation
was starting to boom in california
and hillenburg wanted to be part of it
he temporarily left behind the marina
and went to grad school for animation
joe murray who created rocco's modern
life saw some of hillenberg's animation
work and asked him to come direct
episodes of his nickelodeon show martin
olsen a writer on rocko's modern life
and the office opposite hillenbergs
read an educational comic book called
the intertidal zone
that hillenberg had created while he was
working at the marina olsen
encouraged him to revisit it for a
possible show the book taught
kids about tide pools their guide a sea
sponge
this sea sponge that hillenberg reworked
into spongebob was meant to embody the
boyish flair of pee-wee herman
but also took inspiration from old
school comedians like jerry lewis and
stan laurel
like oliver hardy to stan laurel however
spongebob would need a sidekick
hillenberg chose a starfish named
patrick because while starfish looked
dumb and slow
they are actually very active and
aggressive patrick i don't think guambo
is a real word
come on you know i
wombo he she
me
[Music]
wumbo wing i wonder if a fall from this
height would be enough to kill me
the study of wumbo it's first grade
spongebob
the rest of the world of bikini bottom
took shape and spongebob officially
became nickelodeon's first ever original
saturday morning cartoon when it debuted
on may 1 1999. he and his gang of
underwater friends have been a household
name
ever since within the first month of
television
spongebob overtook pokemon as the
highest rated saturday morning cartoon
uniquely of the 61 million viewers 20
million were adults
with adults on board in addition to kids
a cash cow was born and by early 2000's
there were video games
toys books blankets and just about every
household item you could slap a
character on
275 episodes and counting spongebob is
the longest running nickelodeon show
ever averaging more than 140 million
worldwide viewers
every season he was number one
[Music]
in 2002 hillenburg left the series to
focus on the first spongebob movie
adventure
the spongebob squarepants movie with a
much larger budget for one movie than a
season of tv
hillenberg was able to pay homage to the
movies that pee-wee hermann and laurel
and hardy start in
by giving spongebob a quest the search
for king neptune's stolen crown
this brought spongebob and patrick to
the surface for a high stakes adventure
this spongebob squarepants movie was
released in 2004 and became an instant
classic for a younger generation
while the tv series continued on without
hillenberg many of the original series
staff
also left but returned to work on the
second theatrical movie with hillenberg
for fans those 11 years in between
movies was like spongebob waiting for
the bus at rock bottom
nevertheless the second feature film the
spongebob movie sponge out of water was
released in 2015.
this movie showed spongebob and his arch
nemesis working together to take back
the krabby patty secret formula
after sponge out of water more than
doubled the box office of the first film
with 325 million dollars earned globally
a third feature film went into
production immediately
these dreams finally come
however due to the coven 19 pandemic the
third feature film the spongebob movie
sponge on the run
had its release push from summer 2020 to
march 2021
where it will debut as an online rental
in sponge on the run spongebob and
patrick embark on another adventure
this time to the lost city of atlantic
city in search of spongebob's beloved
pet snail gary
with emmy win starting in 2010 and a few
movies under his belt spongebob
squarepants next
look to conquering broadway
spongebob squarepants the broadway
musical concerns the 48 hours left
before mount humungus on nearby volcano
will erupt and wipe bikini bottom off
the map
musical numbers included original music
and lyrics from the flaming lips arrow
smith steve tyler and joe perry
john legend sara bareilles lady
antebellum
cindy lauper panic at the disco plain
white tees
yolanda williams they might be giants
t.i
and jonathan colton all told there were
356
live performances of the musical on
broadway and by the end of its run it
had garnered 12 tony award nominations
tying the mean girls musical with the
most nominations in 2018
and friends it did win one so that's an
emmy and a tony for mr squarepants
spongebob is halfway to an
egot just needs one oscar win and one
grammy win
and the rare feat is all his can you
picture it just use your
[Music]
imagination
still as fun as it is to envision
spongebob as an egot alongside rita
moreno audrey hepburn and whoopi
goldberg
we all know the real reward spongebob is
waiting for is to get his driver's
license
hello mrs i'm all set for my driving
test
[Applause]
mrs puff maybe someday
[Music]
you